bonjour à tous alors ces deux semaines
du nouveau parlons-en du nouveau il
était temps qu'ils ont rencontrée je
vous écoute hall totalement de ski ils
se sont plantés dans les mesures on l'a
décidé on perd un sac de couchage top la
souche pas mal mon petit coin on rend
utile l'inutile et vous a recruté je
sais pas où on m'a dit de venir
on voulait tant parler mais venir pour
faire quoi
les objets inutiles arrive par la base
nautique
mettez vous au travail avant que je
transforme d'autres conventions de stage
en confettis
avec la porte à ressort
plus d'efforts ou ses brillants le
second enfin rendez vous est arrivé et
je trouve très bien il fait peur je suis
venue acheter le petit coin j'ai ici une
proposition de contrat je te présente la
déprimante global est passé vous avez
ruiné cette voie vous avez posé système
binaire pour circuler voulez savoir ce
que j'appris question
c'est 15 métiers au travail c'est juste
une fois s'il vous plaît enfin bien sûr
suffisait de demander
action premier courrier au président
gaston a pu travailler en 20 minutes que
depuis six mois
burnout pardon
[Musique]